the european commission has reached a
deal with drug makers pfizer and
biontech
to double its order of their covid
vaccine the move secures the eu nearly
half the two firms global output of the
jab
this year the commission has come under
fire recently for europe's slow
vaccination rollout
here's commission president obama
explaining what the deal means for the
bloc
with the new agreement we could purchase
a total
of up to an additional 300 million doses
of the biotech pfizer vaccine
in other words this will allow us to
double the amount of doses
of biotech fiber let's go right to
brussels dw's terry schultz is standing
by for us there welcome terry
what does this deal actually include
yes sumi as european commission van der
lyon just said
this will double the number of pfizer
biontech
vaccines that the european commission
has purchased and
this is not a small issue because the
commission is under fire for having
purchased at the beginning too few and
too
slowly the number of doses that the the
population of almost half a billion
needs
so every additional purchase that
they're allowed to make
of course the commission will hope that
this lessens the criticism of them
and until this week this biotech pfizer
vaccine was the only one approved in the
european union of course
earlier this week moderna was also
approved adding 160 million doses
and as we listen to these numbers it
seems awfully high sumi but we have to
remember that since
every person needs two doses you're only
going to be able to vaccinate half the
number
of people that you hear um the the uh
purchase of the vaccine so when she says
that
we're going to have 600 million of the
biotech pfizer vaccine that's going to
be of course just 300 million people
right that's important to keep in mind
so what do you think this agreement will
mean for the eu-wide rollout
of course it's encouraging to know that
there will be more vaccinations
available but the problem really hasn't
been
buying them the problem is producing
them and the facilities are
you know in a dead neck run producing
the
the the drug as fast as possible but
there have been delays
both in produ production and in
transport especially with this biotech
pfizer vaccine because
it needs these ultra cold conditions
that not all countries were able to
to create at the beginning so some of
the shipments had to be delayed
some of the shipments actually had to be
thrown out because they weren't stored
properly
the moderna vaccine can be stored at
normal freezer temperatures so that also
will help
but there simply isn't enough capacity
to produce the high numbers of vaccines
that the public is demanding now also
this week we heard
that a new facility to be built there in
marburg germany
is going to be up and running for the
biontech pfizer vaccine
so that's going to be very encouraging
but as ursula van der lion said this
morning we are only talking about
the second quarter of this year for
for the new pfizer biotech jabs to come
into production and only by the end of
this year will the
the full shipment be able to be
fulfilled so people need to keep in mind
that the rollout is not immediate you
can buy them but it doesn't mean you're
going to have them in your arm anytime
soon
and you have the eu actually
coordinating this mammoth task and the
member states doing the rollout so
how is that going that's right and i
think
sometimes it's it's appropriate to
defend the european commission because
they buy them
they purchase them but it's up to member
states to deliver them and implement a
vaccination program
and governments are each taking their
own their own path we've of course seen
germany and france criticized for having
a slow rollout
but now this week there's some
additional criticism sumi
and that is that it's it's been learned
that while germany was
president of the european council the
second half of last year
and and uh tasked with shepherding all
27 governments into making their
purchases together to have extra
leverage to make these big
procurements it also on the side
negotiated its own deal
with vaccine makers and that's something
that a lot of countries are are not
happy about germany of course
the wealthiest eu country a very
powerful country and at the time
the european council president so this
is something that the european uh that
the european commission
and the german government are being
asked about how was it really ethical
for germany to purchase
additional doses on this side uh ursula
van der leyen says that it did not break
the european
commission agreement that countries are
allowed to purchase additional doses
and that germany's extra vaccines will
come only after the commission shipment
is fulfilled
dw's terry schultz reporting from
brussels good to talk to you
deaths from the coronavirus have reached
a new one-day high here in germany
despite an ongoing nationwide lockdown
figures from the country's public health
agency show 1188 covet related deaths in
the past
24 hours and almost 32 000
new covet-19 cases were recorded that's
a little less than the previous peak in
mid-december but health officials warn
actual numbers could be higher
hans brown to our political
correspondent joins me now to talk some
more about this
hans how do we explain this new record
death toll
well the death figures are always
delayed by a couple of weeks after the
infection figures have peaked in other
words what we are seeing now are the
deaths
that are the result of the peaks in
infections that were recorded
mid-december
it always takes about a week or two
before people actually have symptoms
then it takes a while for them to go to
hospital
if they do go to hospital and then it
takes a while for them to die if they do
die so
the figures we see now are a factor of
the high infection rates that we had in
mid-december
and looking at that this means that the
infection rates still are high
and uh inevitably the in
the death toll the death figures will
continue to be high for at least another
two or three weeks
and almost 32 000 new infections germany
doesn't seem to have a grip
on the virus is this the mutant virus
train hitting the country or more
testing
after the holidays or maybe something
else
well the mutant strain hasn't really hit
germany as far as we know
there haven't been that many
investigations of uh to what extent that
strain
is at the moment present in germany
although a couple of cases have been
recorded
so that's probably not the reason there
is a number of factors
that play a role here partly it has to
do with the festive season
and the number of cases being reported
now
is higher because they were not reported
in the festive season around new year
and
there was a public holiday two days ago
also in parts of germany so that's one
factor the other factor is that indeed
the number of tests has picked up again
since the festive season
but in the end it means that infection
rates do remain high in germany because
the lockdown
measures so far have not been as
effective as people had hoped
and with this spike in casualties the
urgency for a rollout of covert
vaccinations
is even more pressing and it seems
people here in germany are increasingly
willing to get the job hence stay with
us we'll talk
some more after this report
injections to beat infections hopes for
progress in the battle against the
coronavirus
are focused on the vaccines but success
in developing them
and the accelerated approvals process
will be of little use if people won't
come forward to be vaccinated
75 percent of germans now say they are
prepared to get one of the vaccines
compared with november many more people
are saying it's not just
likely but definite that they will and
the number of people not planning to
face the needle is dropping it's now
less than a quarter of the population
some say that for those who do get
vaccinated rules should be eased
hotels and restaurants for instance
could be reopened for those with proof
of vaccination
others think the idea would create
unnecessary division
the german public seems to share that
skepticism
nearly three-quarters say the rules
should be the same for everybody
even if it were proved that vaccination
means people cannot infect others which
is not yet clear
in the eu the european commission
handled the ordering of vaccines
this was done so that all eu countries
could benefit from the bloc's
negotiating power
and smaller nations were not
disadvantaged but critics say
it slowed the arrival of vaccines and
may have influenced the choice of which
drugs to buy
such concerns have not dampened german
support for european cooperation
seventy percent of people think it was
right not to have eu nations competing
against
each other to secure vaccines
looking ahead everyone is longing for
the end of the pandemic
when will lockdowns masks and distancing
be a thing of the past half of germans
think restrictions will be lifted this
year
but a third are gloomier not expecting a
return to normal until 2022
and some germans think corona measures
will not be lifted for a long time
perhaps never
quite a lot of pessimism here in germany
hence what are the hurdles and
projections
for return to some kind of normality
well i mean one on the one hand we've
seen that the lockdown measures so far
have not had the effect that
the government and everybody else has
hoped for so
the major hope now concentrates on being
vaccinated on a very widely distributed
vaccine
and clearly that is not possible at the
moment because the
supply of vaccines is only picking up
very slowly the government only expects
that
enough vaccine for everyone will be
available within six months or so so the
pessimism that we see in these polls
seems to be fairly realistic that the
situation is continuing to be
serious it will continue to be so for
quite a while
and it will take months before everyone
who wants to be vaccinated even though
people
do want to be vaccinated it will take
months before they will be able to get
the job and for the situation then
to be more relaxed hans brandt dwe's
political correspondent thank you very
much
let's take a look at some other
developments in the pandemic now
germany has broken its record for
covet-related deaths in a 24-hour period
the 1188 fatalities were also
accompanied by a spike in new cases
which surpassed
thirty one thousand the us has reported
more than four thousand new coven 19
deaths in the past
24 hours that is a global record nearly
three times greater than number two
brazil
china has sealed off two cities south of
beijing to stem the country's biggest
outbreak in months
people are banned from leaving xinjiang
and qingtai with combined populations of
nearly 20 million
and iran's supreme leader has banned
vaccines from the u.s and britain
in a televised speech ayatollah ali
khamenei said
anti-covet 19 shots developed in either
country
are forbidden
you